Hua Hai
Hello Hi Everyone Welcome To Bana To Video
Tutorial Hoga Its Value There On This
Video Will Discuss Network
Holders Will Not Repulse And And How Can
You Solve Problems
Bluetooth Co Turn On My School Bench
Subscribe First Voters In A
Reader User Click
Inventors
Middling  Miding
Requested Automatically
The Types of Writing Trigger Trigger Trigger
Name of
The The That The That Begin Followed
By Delhi State Skill
Statements And Finally Bright And
Narendra Singh Tax Bracket Time
Represented Before Or After In Events
And Attractive And Can Be Insert Update
Delete  Option Lalit Will Take You To My School
Work Will Know How To That End
[Music]
Free
Subscribe
My
Password Is To
Call Rate Pradesh Will Take You To My
School Editor's Post Mostly Create A
New Data Is Gold Traders Show Android
SQL Command S8  Database
ki prakash
ki lakshmi ramesh
stay in so you can senior professor
dept created strs
next am going to move inside you should
demand use figures rachna videsh
ok no inside this tricks date
of birth creating a different issues so let's
check 50w command is suitable
that newly  Season 2 Table Spoon This Davis Or
Wright First Life In The Tropics
Sorry For Infrastructure Will Create Table
Customers And Verified Between Customers
100 Giver Comment MP4
That Insert Figure Ajay To
A Slap Me To Go Ahead And Creed Me
Customers Tubelight Create Table
Custom Officer
Ki And Halki My Column Name Of His
Customers Ko Id Special Customer Id Is Ghanti
Antioch Danveer Yadav This Customer Place In
India And Will Have The
Name Fixed Mode
9th Rules Customer Also Off Haar Ka Type
Halki Exercise Thirty And Right
This Screen Visibility  OK Sufiyan
successfully created or customer table namo
brigade sangli to right mez difference
trigger command will start with ulti meter
hua tha swar delimitation markar fati end of witch
command
next flight mez create figure
ki
ford bhai liter neem oil ko pilot karma sach
such thing us verified
Voice Mail Right Idea Figure
That Interested Person Then Insert
That Horn
A Mighty Force Lemon B Custom Officer Give
Right For Each Room
I Is Up
That New Daughters Is Luton 0
Alarm Set Nude Art Is Equal To Zero Which Means
Insulting And Values ​​This
Column  In that meanwhile value will convert negative will convert
h20 phone
under
open android app
that and petrol centimeter
lakshmi run stay
in country morning of creative director
knowledge jeans and top tube well juice
and to custom officer
300 gram 300 pintu custom officer values
to 101 dish tv  Customer ID rather
teenagers 2017 Rajdhani Moti customers
James
a question dry disrespect record cast that
102 hind this time we proper sleep in the
jasmine
study straight took
that if bank customer not MS MB found cancer
tumor records the customer ID with 103
exams of thirty-  two to LIC the names in
this I
make light como and finally Bigg
Boss saunth and fourth customer record dart
customer Edison will definitely be
given gas - 39th soil and lag se
di customer mission chala do
hai and right now let me Randhra
ki his nature successful instituted  4 Runs
of the information to all customers table no let see
differences are hot created under eyes
verify trigger which
food
cheese to values ​​of beach volume increase value
systems phone Dravid record to customer so let's see what we have the
customer table mere
falak mira net dahi  Ko Suji 10
Uttar Pradesh Custom Officer Where is
Assistance Process 102 and 103 You Can See
Hair
Triggers Automatically Converted as Well as to Zero
Phone Frequency The Trigger Bihat Created
Date Set New is 202 Effigy of Western
and Eastern Tweet
Headlines Guddu Now at This Point  Se
Trick Crops And Rate Removing Her Head
And A Tent House After Interview Question Giver
Comment Here
Is After Insert
A Figure
That Ravindra Shyampur Wicket To Tables
Customers And Message No Dear 5050 D Column
Have No Value In R Customers Table 12th
Message To Updated To Both
OK sir first Lakshmi create mic customer
table key
no sense witch already have fun customer
steel limited customer one
end Lakshmi DB power means the first one
long beard Colombo T-20 via Bhupathi and
implement right to Edu key and this will be
my primary key  Porn
is next will have day modi customer is going to be
f type worker
that and reduce not null constraint is next
anti email id more customer is second week of
bar ka type and
columbia interested in this birthday
celebrate birthday
subscribe to
Hai So Let's Create And
Tibble And Rate Nine Wickets And Second Table High
Score In To Be
A Message
A Plus Grade Columns Which Will Have
IAEA Board Allu Steam
How To Increase Top Reader Hai
Next Bilha Buddhi
Message That Par Isko Interview Of Interior
Type
Bill  That highway column cold message
that type of any newspaper is luxury all key and
courtyard to set primary keys
that are
apps ID and
message ID let's
create and second table
saharsh vihar time are active curve will be
them to take care love you temple
run vision force  And rate morning plated
and message tubeless will next
hua hai right my after incessant ticket
command flight
delimitation adh hai
next age ki trigger command salary
adhamundi deck
underscore nalanda isko date of birth after
insert
mode on
ki custom
ojsv one
a for each row
a big  In
I just your
nude art
a birth date
that
this channel
donation view in to
insert into and message table
I will give the calling shades
a message lead hand
a message the
values ​​of
nude art lead marking financial
status contest function
k plum oil
Ki give my message write hi followed by
name
ki ford bhai late se please
update your and date of birth ho chuke na boil
right and left
ki oil
se plaster delhi meter
loot ok
so let me kootkar top end recheck
adapted to trigger correctly gaddi
doctrine
adhruv  Big Dipper New Birthday Channel Value
Subscribe
Customer
Message To All
Red J
Why Nay Ho
9th Next Web History To Accept Few Record
Broken Customer Table
Time Appointment Police Custom Topper Ok
Slight Increase In Column Sass Name
e-mail And
Birth Me
Stay
EWill
Vowels of Values ​​First Customer Name Lashes Nancy Ki Crow Thank You My
Email ID Maps Day NCC
Cadet bbc.com
and tell me
that Lachhi Tempo Hidden Cigarette of Birth Channel Main
Halki and Koma Next Customer Late Se
Tani Modi Customer This Ronald Liye Rather The
Email ID  Suchas Ronald Aadhe
hai rather date of birth is 1997
ki and finally willard one more record for
no the customer labs
halke cream ledis is a great
bbc.com ki
and this time also asli
panch due to very help channel all right hai so lets
ramdeen sadak very ok  To
Hai Na Ho Lakshmi Display Deen Message Table
For You So That You Can See The Output
That A Power
Staring Certificate Box
Dahi Ko Suji Juice
Video Russia Information Of Which Is The
First Customer IAEA Board The Fourth ID Hot
Anal Date Of Birth
Subscribe Please Update  Your birthplace
of both can give speech
and updated on 922 fennel and update box first will create
atibal call employers all
right so let me create multiple
latest create table
that employers
rock band i
light my columbus employee id happy
week entity type and will be  In primary
's next meghwal
ni0
ward not
and c the size of child
a cause death will have given that employee will be
appointed to type and finally e will have
the salary of employee salary will be f type loot
scribble
that all right now  Next Step Into
Interview Record To Are Possible Okay
Suicide Note Pad Quality Remind And
Soybean Certainly Seven Recent Best Hair
Oil To Turn On This Is The Meaning Of Is
Next Bill Writer Before Update Then
Command
100 First And Foremost Right Medi Limit
For A Difficult Command
Isolation  Mother
that trigger name apps update endoscope figure listen this to the
top o
is allu s for update
mode on
that i table it is employers
afor
meanwhile a row that
hydride begin
that i
condition intellect of and
ka nude art
salary es is equal  Too late to tenth him
loud alright
din
set
nude art gallery
ki equal 225 se z
lightly collar
karna oil use oil just
that nude art salary is listen in se z din salute
you don't salary
ki tool good achhe se z
this halke ko cm  Poland
islands pet statement
hydrostatic
meter i keeping semicalculations have been done
a b c d employees temple with half salary value servi
in ​​this
that bill updating atibal pm salary koi
210 se land set the new salary 28500 a
little bit shatter salary problem than this  playlist se
z f
hai so let's go ahead and run view
a figure query
and rate
ki normal rate mein use my update command
website update employers
hua hai right set
salary is equal to lakshya rolls royce
servi em getting salary 2000 play list
100 salary
run ok see you can share subscribe to
108 right now select star from
employers
that clutch tendon ok
it 10 behave converted and salary
problem
from this updater 1000 2000
to 2008
that all right now moving and final demu this
time they going to explain how  To delete
comment box healthy example will create
table call salary easier to delete
records in you table using fifty
electric or first and give me your
comment is a
report tracker
and comments 24 useful
sample query more double
a slap menu create may salary tubules
website  CREATE TABLE
THAT SALARY
I LOVE YOU MY JANU THE
COLUMNS
CID WHICH IS SIMPLY
DEATH STATUS PRIMARY WHO WHO IS
KAL GIFT GINGER VOLUME TARGET VALID FROM WHICH
MEANS DATE FROM WHICH Celebs
HEADED
SUBSCRIBE The Channel
Ek Andhra Buddhi Amount
9th Month Will Be F Type Foot
That we can not legal consultant
lakshmi castor create table
one command ok subah operator salary table 9th nothing
is to insert your values ​​will
right insert into salary elk my
school name say a com
website from
photo copy amount
84 right values
that i am first employee id 2101  Forward
Bases
Show Me
That Hand
201 Me In Support Staff 205
That Wrong Proven Amount Is
In That Lightness Allegation Information This Time
Temple Ladies 102 That
And That
Circles To Pilot From Date Loot
Lakshvedhi Amount From That Of
Yesterday Of
That Another Employee ID Target  103 for daily
sex
I first serial mountain se z
ok creation foreign that all right you can verify all should select from salary
em love you can see your
5000 information
all right
's dansh steps to create
that another table date will restore deleted
Russian light  Create table
ki raksedhnairpi tubeless create
kal college se salary delete a
parrot salary dl
ki nav ten will have wash ki
typing teacher and primary ki
hello hello cotton and to increment top reader
hai next bihar bia leaders typing
teaser
ki kal right bollywood from date and not  Tap
This Period Amount Column Switch Off
Type Return Null
Loot
That I Final Ko Long Deleted Set The
Time Will Be Easy Time Time
That Potato Status Deposit Content Is Known As Well
Written With Time And Date Which Are Posted On
Which Call Rate Is
That  Lakshmi Kripa Drishti Bal Ok
now finally let me night my bro
delete trigger command sa oil first declare medi
limited
to how this time using dollar
symbol light create
afigure
that matriculation and lemon also
that salary underscore delete
that before
New Delhi list on table  Salary For
Each Row Had
Tried To Begin
Next Latch Insert
*
That Salary Delete
I Halki I Column Sas Employee ID
A Valid From Net That
No Balance And Tfu Values ​​And White
Balance
Ko Fold Dot Lead
Como Old Dot
Valid From Com Dot Amount
Ajay Ko
Jhal Humko * The
Clouds with Details
Ajay Ko Ajay Ko Sliced
Solid Pomegranate
Meanwhile Food Delivery A All Right Now Let Me
Go Ahead and Delete One Under Salary Table
Side Delete From Salary Em Vaishya
Employee ID Is Later Se Z
Ki  Lakshmi Ram Discovery
Stop Switch Off Success Fully Deleted One
Period
Records In The Table No If You
See Habit Table Tennis Salary Deleted Love You Will Find This Information
Presented
In The Salary Digit Kollam To Be Deleted
Wave Information Officer Employee ID 103
video9
Final Column Deleted
Subscribe to
is and rate is good top and just give every
step of tweet in this tempo
sophisticated you is trick us started
with difference trigger bean
selected customer table and
verified this customer
subscribe
Video subscribe
button 208 the
state will not even after inserted it
Been Created Two Tables Customers One End
Message Subha Raw
Customs Duty On Both His Missing We
Post Na Sikhayen
Customer Please Update Your Data
And
Big
Dipper Update Crops And Finally Bigg Boss
Ko
Subscribe The Video then
subscribe to the Page
Hello Hi Tube White Vinegar Subscribe
Disrespectful  WhatsApp
Magar Tere Hussan
Adhik Hai YouTube Channel